quelques heures à peine après la
réunification helmoud Cole le nouveau
chancelier de l'Allemagne Uni a tenu à
rassurer ses partenaires européens nous
allons nous engager pour l'unité
européenne avec la même détermination
que pour notre unification a déclaré
elmou Cole dans un message envoyé à tous
les gouvernements du monde il faut dire
que le géant allemand a de quoi faire
peur au reste de l'Europe hélè
rizacher près de 79 millions d'habitants
sur 15 Landers 10 à l'ouest 5 à l'est et
Berlin la Nouvelle République fédérale
d'Allemagne est devenue la nuit dernière
la troisème puissance économique
mondiale et la première puissance
commerciale d'Europe mais en absorbant
l'Allemagne de l'Est la RFA va devoir
payer très cher selon les experts les
plus optimistes il faudra au moins 15
ans avant que l'ancienne RDA en pro
chômage ne rattrape sa sœur de l'Ouest
coût de l'opération au moins 160
milliards de francs par an le prix de la
réunification sera le thème principal de
la campagne pour les élections générales
du 2 décembre prochain en attendant
helmou Cole réalise son rêve diriger
l'Allemagne réunifiée la capitale
allemande est Berlin mais pour l'instant
le gouvernement continue de siéger à
bonne avec C nouveaux ministres venu de
l'Est sans portefeuille le Parlement
s'élargit de 144 députés est allemands
qui siègeront au côté des 519 de l'ouest
jusqu'aux élections depuis la nuit
dernière l'ensemble de la législation de
RFA est étendue à la nouvelle- Allemagne
et l'armée de RDA a cesser
d'exister l'Allemagne unie qui reste
membre de l'OTAN a prévu de limiter ses
à 370000 soldats dont 50000 seulement
issu de l'ex armée de
RDA la Nouvelle République fédérale
d'Allemagne retrouve la presque totalité
de ses frontières d'avantgerre mais le
spectre du passé nazi et militariste
interdit tout rêve de puissance après
plus de 40 ans de séparation entre le
communisme à l'est et l'expérience
démocratique à l'ouest les Allemands ne
se connaissent plus très bien tout
occupés à se retrouver ils veulent
conjurer le passé et s'intégrer dans
l'Europe M